hi guys scifi recapped here
before we start
warning spoilers ahead
today i'm going to explain an american
science fiction movie called pixels
in 1982 there's a 13 year old boy named
sam brenner he informs his friend will
cooper that a new arcade in town is
opening they are excited to go to the
arcade where there are many new arcade
games inside arriving there brenner
discovers that he can master the games
by spotting patterns even though it is
his first time playing the game on the
other hand cooper is not good enough at
playing games
knowing that brenner is awesome at games
cobra gives him a flyer for the arcade
game world championship and says that
brenner should try his skills at the
championship after that they meet ludlow
lemonsoff aka the wonderkid and one of
the famous opposers named eddie plant
aka the fireblaster
the mc says that a time capsule
containing all current events will be
launched by nasa into space with the
hope that the time capsule can be a
message for extraterrestrial life long
story short ed manages to get the
highest score in pac-man while brenner
gets the highest score in galaga
centipede as a result the two of them
will play in the final game donkey kong
to find out who is the winner of the
championship
while they are playing eddie
intentionally mentions the pattern of
the game so that sam loses his focus and
ends up losing the game
brenner feels sad about his defeat
because he initially thought that he
could win the game
in the present day it can be seen that
they have grown up brenner works as an
installer of home theater systems while
cooper is the unpopular president of the
united states because he is often mocked
by the media in guam a u.s military base
suddenly receives a threatening signal
from outer space the military base is
besieged by an extraterrestrial force
attacking in the form of galaga that
turn pieces of the base into small
glowing cubes eventually one of the
soldiers is abducted by the aliens
back to brenner's life he works at the
home of lieutenant colonel fan patton
and her son matthew van patten who tells
brenner that his mother is going through
a divorce
after finishing his work he comes to
violet's room to ask for payment
apparently he hears violet crying in the
closet
therefore he comes in and immediately
comforts her by listening to her current
situation because he gets carried away
brenner wants to kiss her but sadly
violet refuses shortly after he gets a
call from cooper asking him to go to the
white house
on his way brenner reunites with violet
who turns out to have the same
destination as him
soon cooper shows him the recording of
galaga aliens attacking the us military
base earlier and turning it into pixels
cooper in disbelief asks him to explain
what happened
however his explanation is not accepted
by the security council because he is
just an ordinary civilian as a result he
drives his van home
suddenly a young man calls his name from
the back it turns out that the man is
ludlow his childhood friend
he then brings brenner back to his house
where he says that the alien used the
classic video game designs to attack he
shows a footage taken from a television
show in the 1980s which contains the
alien's plan to invade earth thus they
show the footage to cooper afterwards
brenner determines that aliens have
misinterpreted the video cassette in the
time capsule as a declaration of war
consequently they will attack with
technology based on the video games
challenging earth to a battle where if
the aliens win three rounds they will
conquer earth
furthermore ludlow also says that the
next attack will happen in india
unfortunately cooper refuses to warn
india of something that is not certain
to happen
sure enough the aliens attack as
arkanoid paddles which sling the balls
of light to destroy the taj mahal
they also abduct a bystander as a bonus
later brenner and ludlow are taken to
the armaments department led by violet
she shows them that the pixels can be
disabled by light cannons developed by
her they are also asked to train navy
seals to fight back against the aliens
by showing them how to play these old
games the following day cooper is with
his wife jane at a bakery when suddenly
his assistant comes and tells him that
the next attack will be in london
therefore all of the soldiers
immediately go to the park which is
predicted to be attacked by the aliens
at night it is revealed that the aliens
attack in the form of the video game
galaga centipede brenner tells the navy
seals to shoot for the head and
anticipate the unpredictable pattern but
the soldiers still have no clue about it
because of that brenner and ludlow are
able to step in and shoot them down
the final centipede bursts into town and
nearly devours a little boy but luckily
brenner manages to destroy the final
centipede when they are celebrating
their victory the aliens send a message
using the fantasy guys to congratulate
earth they also send a trophy in the
form of a dog from duck hunt besides
that the aliens remind them that they
are still leading two to one and the
next challenge will be even more
difficult than before knowing this they
agreed to find someone else to help them
the group decides to retrieve eddie from
a prison sentence for fraud he makes
self-serving demands in exchange for his
help some of which cooper finally agrees
to a few moments later violet receives
an information that the next game will
happen in new york city the team goes
there immediately and discovers that the
next boss is pac-man which they must
participate as the ghosts against it
therefore violet presents the team with
four mini cooper cars which were already
armed to defeat pac-man they are also
assisted with toru iwatani the creator
of pac-man they head to the city where
pac-man is chomping through everything
after that toru tries to confront the
pac-man but his hand gets bitten instead
brenner ludlow and eddie continue to
chase after pac-man eddie manages to hit
the first pac-man after violet notices
him moving at supersonic speeds around
the board at one point the second pacman
eats a power pellet giving it a 10
seconds to be able to eat the ghosts
consequently it chomps ludlow's car as
he jumps out from the car just at the
right time eddie hits the second pac-man
again to save ludlow the third pac-man
causes eddie to fall into the river
leaving brenner as the final ghost
unluckily it finds another power palette
near the parking garage brenner
immediately comes down and drives
backwards through the parking garage
on the count of ten he is able to beat
the last pac-man who is about to eat him
after winning their second game they get
cubered as a winning trophy
the next day brenner asks violet to be
his date in the celebration party which
she accepts when he spends time with her
at the party the aliens suddenly send
another message declaring the challenge
for the planet has been forfeited
because someone cheated outside matthew
discovers eddie used a speed sheet in
his classes which allowed him to beat
pac-man beforehand
it also explains how he beat brenner in
donkey kong a long time ago afterwards
eddie flees while maddie is abducted by
the aliens
back to the house hubert tells them that
the aliens leave peacefully until they
felt threatened by the time capsule
because they did not know it was just a
video game
subsequently the group realizes that
they have to go to the spaceship and
stop the aliens the next morning the
aliens launch a massive attack in
washington dc using both good and bad
characters from classic video games
cooper finally joins the team to get
into the spaceship while ludlow stays to
fight meanwhile an alien takes the form
of lady lisa a character on whom ludlow
had a crush since childhood he
eventually persuades lady lisa to choose
love and side with the humans eddie also
returns to the fight because he wants to
make amends
brenner violet cooper and cubert are
summoned to the alien's mothership where
they face the alien leader in the form
of donkey kong starting from the lowest
level with the alien's captives at the
top level
as the group dodges barrels and
fireballs brenner is losing hope until
maddie tells brenner that eddie was
cheating on him many years ago causing
him to realize that he should have been
the winner at that time with his
confidence drastically increased brenner
defeats the donkey kong this causes the
alien's characters to self-destruct
including lady lisa which causes ludlow
to feel sad
the team is hailed as heroes by cooper
himself and a peace agreement is reached
with the aliens
in the meantime eddie apologizes to
brenner for cheating and admits that he
is the best in the world although ludlow
is saddened that lady lisa was gone
hubert suddenly transforms its likeness
to lady lisa
lastly brenner and violet become a
couple while eddie gets to meet serena
williams and martha stewart like he
always dreamed of the aliens also
restored toru's hand before their
departure
a year later lady lisa and ludlow marry
and have cuber children
subscribe to watch more videos like this
turn on notifications
and leave a like to help the channel out
thank you for watching